[Applause]
so Kristen you wrote a new book so
what's it about I wrote a book
um called I'm no philosopher but I got
but I got thoughts that's my favorite
part I know me too many meditations for
Saint Sinners and the rest of us and in
the shutdown like so many people I felt
lost I didn't know what to do I wanted
to be creative and my my lit agent
called said why don't you write another
book I said are you kidding no way that
felt like I had a book report due every
second and I started looking at my own
journals and reading my own journals
y'all and I found some tough things
which I shared and also really funny
things like my mom always said had the
patience of Job and I said well and she
goes you need to read the book and I
read it and I said he bitched his head
off Joe bitched his head off why do I
wanna anyway I love that my mother was
like be careful what you asked for never
ask for patience my mother literally
told me that was good she's like I think
God will test you yeah that's true it
will right happen and there was one note
that I found that I put in there and
talk about
um Elizabeth Edwards remember her she
was married to that politician John
Edwards yes and
she says this she stood in the storm and
when the wind did not blow her way she
adjusted her sails I love what's that
mean to you to me it means pivot pivot
yeah also we always think about all the
bad times how are we going to Pivot out
of that and yeah I think about it with
the good times too like
today for example I had five different
things I wanted to wear and this is just
a very surfacy thing to bring up but I'm
excited I get to be here and meet talent
and talk to you yeah
but I was like none of my outfits are
fitting you know Nashville and back to
the business yeah I'm like but you get
to be here girl don't be getting all
about yourself you get to be here yeah
and just pivot think about anything even
even the bad stuff that none of us wants
to talk about depression falling down
and getting back up
give yourself a second have some ice
cream be sad be sad and then pivot and
move on sit with it and then let it go
yeah because while you're there so
actually you did I believe it was a
commercial during the Super Bowl it was
like for mental health why was this
important to you is this kind of does
this coincide with this it does uh that
super moat commercial was for my home
state of Oklahoma and it was really
geared towards men who are afraid to say
I'm depressed or I can't you know I
can't get this thing off my back and
it's Kristin Chenoweth on his back and
I'm irritating him the whole time but it
really responded to me for first of all
let's normalize that a lot of people
feel sad scared depressed down doesn't
matter what age you are it doesn't
matter how much you've accomplished
especially in the mail it's not cool to
be and if especially in the south in the
South they don't allow men to like they
don't do therapy you know and I wanted
to be a part of that and then like I
said about four months ago I I sort of
crashed and burned and I'd never done
that in my whole career
yeah I mean me neither
so fear
but with the schedule and piling
everything on yeah and I think about you
too because you do a lot of different
things yeah we have to you know the
Millennials say I need a second for
myself and I used to laugh at it now I'm
saying Millennials I'm taking a page out
of your book yeah no it is important to
slow down I know I did that and then I
just got busy again
yeah and I think sure yeah in general
right I'm working on it oh
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
y'all have a great great night
[Music]